to thank professor Browning's and his
team at European Environment Agency
experts who contributed to this
excellent clear evidence based document
which sends and an emergency message but
first of all it's also at the very right
timing just a week before the European
Green Deal going to be published and it
will be always a great evidence to
return take a look where we are and that
this is why we need those decisions to
be fostered I'm also glad that this
press conference is led by the executive
vice president France timmermans as we
are 2021 sums up the five past years
progress indentifies three major
shortages so systemic strategic approach
which was lacking implementation gap and
of course addressing public finances so
that they would definitely promote
sustainability this all can be only
achieved at the executive level with the
crucial role in leading speaking on the
positive note this report also very
clearly states that you managed to
reduce some pressure not enough but some
pressure while still enhancing
prosperity and well-being of our
citizens I'm glad that for my mandate I
feel that is direct response to SOE R
2023 major tasks for me
biodiversity strategy 2030 it's a direct
respond for protection of our
environment
which is clearly showing the trends it
wasn't enough and don't get me wrong
strategy is not going to be enough
implementation gap also has to be filled
it also has to be funded enough but most
importantly we also have to get every
in order in order to be credible outside
the you as we speak of use of resources
which is highlighted again
in the report circular economy action
plan will be the answer for that but it
is important to get businesses involved
and create a market for them those SMEs
pioneers who will be the first ones
offering circular economy solutions they
have to be funded and have a good access
to capital when we speak about citizens
health problems zero pollution ambition
is important cornerstone of the Green
Deal but of course also of my mission
letter
it is only it is not only that EU finds
itself in disjunction it's the whole
planet but it is very important to get
our house in order
fixing every corner of it then we can
only be credible in the world we can
come with our agenda and negotiate with
our partners I would say that we cannot
predict the future but we can definitely
create it and this report evidence based
with excellent data gathered shows that
very clearly thank you very much